hello grammarians hello david hello
rosie so today we're going to talk about
understatement and overstatement and i
could not be more excited this is like
the coolest thing that's happened to me
all week oh my gosh really
no i mean i'm excited this is a really
interesting topic but i was deliberately
overstating yeah i mean it's pretty cool
but that is that does that is a perfect
example david of what overstatement is
so
we're gonna look at a couple examples of
what writers will do sometimes to
i would say both understanding and
overstatement really help to drive a
point home
we're going to start with
understatement so david do you want to
read this sentence sure
so you kidnapped my dog drove to new
orleans without telling anyone and ate
the last cookie that i was saving yeah
i'm like vaguely unhappy
this is a horrible thing that just
happened
so when you said yeah i'm like vaguely
unhappy
after this huge list of horrible things
that this supposed friend has done you
know it's clear that
that you're more than just a little
vaguely unhappy
to be clear grammarians rosie did not do
any of these things
thank you david this is a this sentence
is a work of fiction
thank you for letting me off the hook
there you are
so what what we're trying to express in
this sentence
uh
is that this is something that should
make the speaker or the writer quite
unhappy um but what we're doing here is
deliberately understating
the case
to further drive home the point that
this is actually quite serious
exactly
so ironically while the writer is using
minimizing language saying i am vaguely
unhappy or like vaguely unhappy which
serves to further qualify that statement
the fact that they're saying that after
such a litany of sins like
the cookie even that's just oh
really serves to drive home the opposite
effect
so this is a textbook example of
understatement
all right so we've seen an example of
understatement let's take a look at what
an overstatement might look like
my life is over i got a d on the midterm
i am dead i am literally a skeleton
oh wow
so
this is a great
a great example of
overstatement so we know this isn't true
right
amid a d on your midterm not great but
is it truly an actually the end of
someone's life no and this author this
writer knows that knows what they're
saying because skeletons can't write
exactly and you might have also heard of
hyperbole which is what this is this is
like way exaggeration
but it serves to drive home this
person's point that they feel really bad
that they gotta deon this midterm and
this is a very effective way of
conveying to us
how upset they are even though they're
not literally a skeleton and they don't
think they're literally a skeleton
i think the emotional impact of this is
much more effective than it would be
if i just said i am very upset because i
got a d on my midterm like i think this
is more expressive
um
and certainly it's not
true
but i think there's an interesting way
to play with over an understatement in
order to get
feelings across
i think
i think there's like a little bit of a
taboo in
american english speaking culture
to
[Music]
to literally say the state of your
emotions um
and so we've discovered these cultural
idioms through which we transmit emotion
so like compare the following two
examples delivered by rosie okay
i'm very angry
or
yeah you could say i'm i'm a little
upset
now rosie is using
understatement that i i think and i feel
that the the statement that uses
understatement actually conveys
more anger
because it's more socially acceptable in
the united states to somewhat publicly
repress your emotions
yeah exactly i mean you could hear
somebody say yeah i think i'm i'm pretty
upset about that and they're kind of
laughing but they're upset
you can see the glorious subtlety of
these
language techniques and and i understand
this this can make english a minefield
for people trying to learn the language
because the subtext of what you're
saying uh with overstatement and
understatement is more important than
the text itself
exactly
and i it's very difficult to
to learn to interpret those cues there
are plenty of native speakers who have
trouble with it
it's true and
it's just something that you'll you can
keep an eye out for when you're reading
and also when you're talking to people
it may start to you may start to spot
them more as you as you listen
and i suspect that if you listen and you
study i have this sneaking minute
suspicion
that you can learn anything
david out rosie out
that was awesome
that was fun